all right i have something for you today
that i think some of you are going to
think is funny
but it's really not it's actually really
really horrifying
um i don't know how many of you remember
this guy stu peters we're gonna look
back at in a bit we're gonna look back
at a clip from a couple weeks ago where
stu peters said
he believes that the flu or covid that
he got
was given to him deliberately like a
weapon and he said that without any
evidence he interviewed yesterday
an anti-vaccine actress known as crystal
teeny
that's crystal teeny
who
i i there's no way for me to say this
without just saying what it is
she claims that when she's near
vaccinated people she has anal bleeding
okay
um
she she believes that that symptom is
being caused
by people shedding the vaccine onto her
that it causes anal bleeding
um she's a dancer model choreographer
type person hair stylist i think
she has hair accessories and makes yoga
elements
and she is anti-vaxx take a listen to
what she had to say listen carefully
because she uses coded language insanely
alarming
clots yes
okay yeah well that is absolutely
alarming have you visited with a doctor
a physician um and and talked about this
or i mean are you pretty much have you
made up in your own mind that if you
were to go speak to a doctor that they
would tell you that you're nuts that
this just doesn't happen that this
doesn't exist despite the fact that it's
proven that it it does exist several
experts have said that is that why
you're hesitant to go or have you gone
i have not i have not gone and people
might feel like maybe you should go to
the doctor but i know exactly what
they're going to say and especially
because i am not vaccinated they're
going to say that there's no relation
and i'm not going to waste my time doing
that after all the research that i've
done and i know that you have done uh we
do know that there is a relation to it
and i i actually did a video like way
back when in the very beginning when
people started getting vaccinated
noticing problems with their menstrual
cycles and things like that now for me
obviously there are people getting
nosebleeds anal bleeding and vaginal
bleeding i will do the process of
elimination i am not vaginally bleeding
or bleeding from the nose so okay so
understand what she says she says some
people are getting nosebleeds vaginal
bleeding or anal bleeding i'm not
getting vaginal and i'm not getting nose
bleeding so she's saying i'm getting
anal bleeding when i'm near vaccinated
people
the fact that it is something more
serious since obviously women menstruate
and um it's really really scary so i'm
not going to go to a doctor it does
resolve over a period of time it's been
almost a week and i am still
experiencing the symptoms so guys
if she i'm not joking around here
if she's telling the truth this could be
colon cancer
it could be a bunch of other things
it's
i if she's just lying and saying being
near she's not even saying these are
side effects from getting vaccinated
she's saying these are side effects from
being near vaccinated people when she
goes near a vaccinated person she has
anal bleeding for a week and then it
resolves she says
if she's lying then it's crazy
if she's telling the truth she really
needs to be evaluated i mean i'm not
kidding around
and this is maybe the craziest show i've
ever seen this is a reminder of when stu
peters claimed that someone
infected him deliberately with the virus
as opposed to like he just caught it i
wouldn't be surprised if this so-called
cold the virus the flu that i have right
now was a targeted attack on media do
you speculate that some of that might be
going on as well right a targeted attack
yeah i mean absolutely like the bio
weapon being released on you this this
sociopath tony fauci when he
chimerically engineered this
taxpayer-funded
lab-originated intentionally released
wuhan china virus and i should make
clear just so we don't get any in any
trouble on youtube the claims being made
right now by stupiders are untrue i mean
that could probably be used against
people automatically i mean people
republicans conservatives talk show host
people being targeted with this vibe
okay anyway you guys get it he he caught
a virus against which he was not
vaccinated and he says it must have been
a targeted attack
really scary stuff if these people
really believe this stuff then they do
need to be medically evaluated if they
are just lying then it's extremely
immoral what they are doing a few things
i talk about frequently uh government
surveillance of private citizens big
tech corporations following you around
online tracking done by isps of users
all of these parties can see things that
you're doing online if they can see your
ip address that's why you should hide
your ip address using atlas vpn it's
only a dollar 39 a month you install it
click one button it stays on and you
forget about it masking your ip address
like this also lets you watch content on
streaming platforms only available in
other countries it's really easy it also
helps keep you safe from hackers and
online identity theft you can use atlas
vpn's data breach monitor to see if your
personal info or passwords have been
exposed in online leaks and don't forget
you can also give atlas vpn as a gift
atlas vpn is having a special holiday
sale you get 86 off comes out to a
dollar 39 a month plus you'll get three
months free go to atlas v dot p n slash
pacman and use the promo code pacman